وفي واشنطن قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن انه اطلع على التقارير عن
الهجوم على على ولا يمكنه تاكيد صحتها
اضاف في مؤتمر صحفي ان واشنطن تاخذ كل ما
يصدر عن الكرملين بقدر كبير من الشك
وستنتظر ظهور الحقائق قبل التعليق على
الروايه الروسيه وقال بلينكل ان القرار
يعود لاوكرانيا بشان كيفيه الدفاع عن
نفسها واستعاده وحده اراضيها وسيادتها
مشيرا الى ان روسيا فشلت استراتيجيا
بالفعل وانا واثق بقدره اوكرانيا على
النجاح في استعاده جزء اكبر من اراضيها
معنى من البيت الابيض مراسله الجزيره وجد
وقفي وجد اذا تشكيك امريكي بالروايه
الروسيه وانتظار لظهور الحقائق كما يقول
بلنكن ماذا في التفاصيل
نعم واضح ان هذه الاداره تنظر بعين الشك
اذا كل ما يصدر عن الكريم فيما يتعلق
بالشان الاوكراني وهذا بدا واضحا من
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه بلينكن هنا في
البيت الابيض مسؤول امريكي رفيع ابلغني
بان الاداره الامريكيه ما زالت تبحث في من
اجل معرفه حقيقه ما حدث وبانه في الوقت
الراهن لا يمكنها تاكيد ما ورد في التقرير
الروسي عن الهجوم المزعوم وبان حتى اللحظه
ايضا ليس بامكانها التحقق من مصداقيه ما
ورد بهذا الشان اذا هذا هو حتى اللحظه
الرد الرسمي للبيت الابيض والاداره
الامريكيه بشكل عام السيء كما ذكرنا هناك
الكثير من التشكيك خاصه وان الاداره
الامريكيه والرئيس بايدن وايضا مسؤولين
كبار اخرين طالما اتهموا الرئيس الروسي
الكذب
وكذلك اخبار مفبركه هذا ورد في اكثر من
تصريح من المسؤولين الامريكيين وهي تنظر
بذات العين الى اليوم الهجوم اليوم على
الكرملين الى ان تتحقق من صحه هذه
المعلومات طبعا بحسب ما علمنا او من من
موقع مجله بوليتيكو فان مسؤول امريكي رفيع
ابلغ
المجله بان الاداره الامريكيه تعتزم تقديم
احاطه
لاعضاء في لجنه الاستخبارات الامريكيه
بمجلس الشيوخ بشان هذا الهجوم وبشان ما
لديها هذا الهجوم ولكن هي عاده الاداره
الامريكيه السيتاميل اكثر الى تصديق
التصريحات الاوكرانيه وقد سمعنا من
الزملاء من الزميل تامر بان اوكرانيا في
جمله وتفصيلا ان يكون هذا الهجوم قد صدر
عن الجانب الاوكراني ذلك ان اوكرانيا اصلا
لم تحقق الاهداف العسكريه الداخله اراضيها
وبالتالي لا يوجد لديها دافع
للتحرك الى الداخل الروسي واعتبرت
اوكرانيا هذا الامر بانه خدعه الاداره
الامريكيه عاده كما ذكرت تميل الى تصديق
التصريحات الاوكرانيه ولكن طبعا هي لديها
مصادرها الخاصه للتحقق ازاءه صحه ما حدث
اليوم في الكرملين شكرا جزيلا لك وجد وقف
مراسلتنا في البيت الابيض